R
WORKERS.
SHAME ON THEM NEVER LISTEN TO
A WORD THEY SAY ABOUT SOCIAL
JUSTICE.
LISA JOINS US NOW.
ISN'T IT JUST UNBELIEVABLE AND
THE REACTION OR LACK OF
REACTION FROM THOSE PEOPLE WHO
LECTURED US ENDLESSLY ABOUT
POLICE BRUTALITY?
>> AND THE IRONY THE LEFT IS
OKAY THEY WENT
AUTHORITARIANISM AS LONG AS
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT ARE IN
CHARGE.
AND THAT IS THE SCARIEST THING
OVER THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS
WITNESSING HOW SUSCEPTIBLE
FREE NATIONS ARE TO TYRANNY.
TRUDEAU TREATING THESE
TRUCKERS AND CANADIANS AS IF
THERE TERRORIST AND WHY?
BECAUSE THEY HOLD QUOTE
UNQUOTE UNACCEPTABLE VIEWS?
LOOK AT WHAT THEY WANT.
ALL THEY WANT IS AUTONOMY IN
THE RIGHT TO SAY NO OVER THEIR
BODY AND VACCINES THAT ARE
EXPERIMENTAL AND INEFFECTIVE.
THAT IS THEIR CRIME.
SO INSTEAD SEE HOW TRUDEAU HAS
TREATED THEM?
HE HAS INVOKED THE EMERGENCIES
ACT.
HE HAS TURNED CANADA INTO A
SO INSTEAD SEE HOW TRUDEAU HAS
TREATED THEM?
HE HAS INVOKED THE EMERGENCIES
ACT.
HE HAS TURNED CANADA INTO A
POLICE STATE.
HE HAS HAD PEOPLE ARRESTED AND
FROZEN BANK ACCOUNTS GO THAT
ALONE WITH THAT MENTALITY LOOK
AT WHAT IS HAPPENING IN THE
UNITED STATES THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TRIED TO LABEL
PARENTS STANDING UP FOR THEIR
KIDS AT THE BOARD DOMESTIC
TERRORIST AND PUT DOD AGAINST
THEM SO THE MARCH TOWARD
AUTHORITARIANISM BOTH HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES AND ABROAD
IS REAL.
PEOPLE NEED TO WAKE UP.
STEVE: I WOULD NOT SAY THE
VACCINES ARE INEFFECTIVE THAT
THEY ARE EFFECTIVE TO PROTECT
YOU BUT NOBODY ALSO THERE IS
NO CASE TO THE MANDATE THAT IS
COMPLETELY UNJUSTIFIED IN ANY
SCIENTIFIC GROUND.
YOU ARE RIGHT THEY LOVE THE
EXCUSE TO PUSH THE CONTROL.
AND IT IS DIRECTED AT THE
EXACT SAME PEOPLE WHO AT THE
BEGINNING OF ALL OF THIS MAKE
SURE WE RECOGNIZE THE HEROISM
OF THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS.
THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS TURNED
AROUND AND DISOBEYED THE
TECHNOCRATS AND POLITICIANS
NOW THEY ARE THE ENEMY.
>> THE REASON I SAID THAT
BECAUSE WE WERE RECENTLY TOLD
IT WOULD STOP TRANSMISSION AND
THAT HAS NOT HAPPENED EVEN
AFTER MULTIPLE SHOTS TO
PREVENT IS WHAT THEY ARE
SAYING.
THAT YOUR POINT, LOOK AT THE
MENTALITY OF THE WESTIN
SOMETHING THAT GOVERNOR OF
CONNECTICUT RECENTLY SAID.
YOU HAVE EARNED YOUR FREEDOM.
HE THINKS HE IS THE LIBERATOR
BUT HE IS THE OPPRESSOR.
YOU HAVE EARNED YOUR FREEDOM.
THAT IS WHAT HE SAID.
BUT HE DOES UNDERSTAND OUR
LOMBARDY IS GOD-GIVEN NOT
GOVERNMENT GIVEN THE
CONSTITUTION PROTECTS THE
GOD-GIVEN LIBERTY FROM THE
GOVERNMENT.
WE WERE BORN FREE WE DON'T
NEED THE GOVERNOR OF
CONNECTICUT TO GIVE US THAT
LIBERTY.
WHAT I AMERICANS TAKE FROM
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN THROUGHOUT
COVID IS TO SEE WHAT ROLE WE
WANT THE GOVERNMENT TO HAVE IN
OUR LIVES.
LOOK AT THE WAY THE LEFT HAS
ABUSE THEIR POWER THEY USE
COVID TO GET MORE POWER AND TO
UNMASK MORE POWER TO FORCE
VACCINES OF PEOPLE AND MASK
MANDATES DEMOCRAT GOVERNOR
DESANTIS HAS DONE IN FLORIDA.
HE IS KEPT AT THREE AND GOT
THE GOVERNMENT OUT OF THE WAY
AND RESPECTED INDIVIDUAL
LIBERTIES.
THE TWO POLITICAL PARTIES.
I HOPE PEOPLE TAKE THAT
MENTALITY AND CLEAR EYED INTO
THE MIDTERMS IN NOVEMBER
BECAUSE IT IS OUR LIVES FOR
FREEDOM AND LIBERTY.
STEVE: IT WAS DEMOCRAT TO MASK
AND DEMOCRATS CLOSE TO
SCHOOLS.
DEMOCRATS SHUT DOWN LOCAL
BUSINESSES.
ALL OF IT UNJUSTIFIED.
NONE OF IT MADE A DIFFERENCE
LOOK AT THE DATA COMPARISON
BETWEEN FLORIDA AND CALIFORNIA
WITH EXTREME SHUTDOWNS THERE
IS NO JUSTIFICATION.
IT'S ALL ABOUT POWER CONTROL